hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and now that all
four nights of the apocalypse have
finally been revealed in the seventh
deadly sin sequel and now that an anime
adaptation has been confirmed for the
sequel i thought that this would be the
perfect time to talk about all four
knights and their insane powers and
abilities the four knights of apocalypse
include the son of meliotis and
elizabeth the son of bonn and elaine the
niece of king arthur and a guy who may
or may not be the secret love child of
merlin so let's get into it you guys
know how this works if you enjoy our
vids and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment it
only takes you a second but it helps me
out a lot with that youtube algorithm
and of course subscribing and hitting
that notification bell is a completely
free but very real way of directly
supporting the channel right now you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar and a lot of you guys
have been doing that already asking me
to make more four nights apocalypse
videos finally this video will of course
contain four nights of apocalypse manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned first up let's talk
about what the four knights of
apocalypse actually are because the true
nature of this group is drastically
different depending on who you ask
according to king arthur and the
inhabitants of camelot these four
knights are prophesized to bring doom
and destruction to the world as such the
knights of camelot are attempting to
hunt down and eliminate each of the four
knights before they become a threat on
the other hand the kingdom of leones has
a completely different view of the four
knights in leones they are often
referred to as the four knights of
prophecy and they are prophesized to
save the world not to destroy it this
drastic difference between how the four
knights are perceived in camelot versus
leonis arises from the bitter rivalry
that these two kingdoms are engaged in
at the beginning of the four nights of
the apocalypse manga for reasons that
are yet unknown to us as of the making
of this video king arthur changed
completely between the end of the
seventh deadly sins manga and the
beginning of the sequel manga he is now
an evil king who wants to exterminate
all the other races and clans except for
humans and because the kingdom of leonis
has a demon on its throne in the form of
meliodas and also because the onus is in
general tolerant of all the races arthur
has a special interest in destroying
leonis the seven deadly sins and the
four knights of the apocalypse our best
guess as to what happened to arthur is
that he was somehow corrupted by chaos
power but that still doesn't explain a
whole bunch of things including why
merlin continues to stay by his side
seemingly enabling his actions these big
questions will definitely be answered
eventually we just have to keep reading
the manga that said we now need to talk
about all four members of the four
knights of the apocalypse and their
powers it is important to note that at
this point in the story all four knights
are just 16 year old teenagers they
haven't coalesced into a formal group
yet and for the most part they don't
really know each other they certainly
don't have a common goal or mission and
they have no idea how or why they are
supposed to either destroy the world or
save it at some abstract point in the
future let's start with the main
protagonist of the story and the first
night of the apocalypse that we meet
right at the very beginning of the
sequel manga i'm of course talking about
percival according to the prophecy
percival is the knight of death and he
was described as a boy with verdant
wing-like hair and yes percival is a boy
with green wing-shaped hair and purple
eyes who looks like he's about 10 even
though he's actually 16. for basically
his entire life he lived on a massive
pillar-shaped mountain called god's
finger where he was raised by his
grandpa vargaze in complete isolation
from the outside world god's finger is
so tall that its tip is located above
the clouds and from the top of god's
finger you can actually see the shadow
of the sky island or sky temple which is
the home of the celestials in the
prisoners of the sky movie the
circumstances surrounding percival's
birth are extremely mysterious all we
know is that his father is a holy night
of camelot named ironside a man who
betrayed king arthur along with his
father and percival's grandfather
vargase at some point ironside
disappeared while vargazet took percival
to god's finger and raised him alone he
also told percival that his father was
dead varghese trained percival from the
age of 3 to become a strong and skilled
fighter due to the fact that he grew up
in isolation percival is extremely
curious about the outside world and once
he does finally emerge from god's finger
he is super excited about everyone and
everything that he sees because percival
has no experience socializing with
people other than his grandpa at first
he is far too naive in his social
interactions and far too trusting of
strangers now the event that triggered
percival's departure from god's finger
and the beginning of his adventure was
the death of his grandfather at the
hands of a knight in red armor who
showed up on god's finger in a floating
boat the red knight fatally wounded
vargaze and seriously wounded percival
as well before departing god's finger
right before dying percival's grandpa
reveals that the red knight is actually
ironside percival's father vargaza had
previously lied to his grandson by
telling him that his father had died
when he was very young percival
desperately wants to know why his father
would attack his grandfather in this way
but vargaze tells him that if he wants
to learn the truth he must track down
ironside and ask him varghezid then
succumbs to his injuries and a
heartbroken percival departs from god's
finger determined to bring ironside to
justice along the way perce will meet
some indispensable friends and allies
and he discovers that he possesses a
number of incredible powers and
abilities so let's talk about those
powers and abilities right now first up
we need to talk about percival's unique
magic which is called hope hope is a
type of magic that is powered by the
hope of the user's allies and by the
faith that the user's allies place in
him so it is literally the power of
friendship and as we all know the power
of friendship is the most powerful
ability in all of anime and manga
according to holy night of camelot
peligard hope could be an extremely rare
type of magic known as hero type magic
which apparently appears only in a tiny
tiny minority of people hope allows
percival to generate a magical aura
around his body or parts of his body and
he can then manipulate this aura in many
different ways the aura allows him to
defend himself by acting as a shield and
reducing the damage from enemy attacks
it also enhances his own physical
strength when he is the one doing the
attacking and it can even heal extremely
serious injuries almost instantly the
aura can also take different shapes in
order to help percival get out of tight
situations for example the aura can take
the form of wings which allows percival
to literally fly this magic can even
absorb the magic attacks of others and
shoot them right back at the attacker
and if that wasn't enough percival is
able to create a bunch of chibi clones
of himself these chibi clones have a
will of their own and they work
tirelessly to help percival if he is
ever in trouble the clones can also heal
percival's injuries and the injuries of
his allies percival possesses the
mysterious ability to instantly drain
all the fluids out of a living being
just by touching the person directly
essentially mummifying them or at least
the part of their body that percival had
come into direct contact with percival
first demonstrated this ability when he
was in a state of extraordinary
agitation and despair as he falsely
believed that all of his friends had
just been killed normal healing magic
cannot reverse the effects of this
strange mummification and only
percival's own hope magic seems capable
of reversing it it goes without saying
that hope magic is incredibly
overpowered and versatile with a huge
number of applications on and off the
battlefield on top of his extremely rare
op magic percival also possesses far
more strength and durability than an
ordinary human percival seems to have
enhanced resistance against drugs and
other types of potions and he has
exceptional lung capacity due in part to
the fact that he grew up at a very high
altitude on top of god's finger now
percival's extraordinary strength
durability and stamina could be due to
the fact that he underwent extensive
physical training since he was only
three years old but there could also be
something else going on here for
instance
percival is able to speak the language
of demons and no one seems to know why
not even percival this suggests that
percival may not be just a normal human
and that he may be of a mixed race
heritage as of the making of this video
we still don't know who percival's
mother is but i have a feeling that
merlin herself may somehow be involved
with his birth that is just speculation
on my part and i made a whole video
talking about merlin potentially being
percival's secret mother but we'll have
to wait and see what happens percival is
also currently in possession of
meliodas's former sword dragon handle
which has been repaired and turned into
a fully functioning sword by hauser
percival is able to use hope magic to
enhance the powers of the sword and as
we know dragon handle is a part of the
coffin of eternal darkness so the fact
that percival has it in his possession
is likely to become important later on
in the story now let's talk about the
second night of the apocalypse that we
meet in the story the son of bonn and
elaine lancelot according to the
prophecy lancelot is the night of war
and he is described as a mysterious boy
with no fixed appearance this is because
as a half fairy lancelot possesses the
ability to shapeshift and in fact when
we first see lancelot in the four nights
of the apocalypse manga we don't even
know that it's him because he appears as
a talking fox who goes by the name sin
get it fox's sin
anyway we actually first met lancelot in
an extra chapter of the original seven
deadly sins manga chapter
346.5 that chapter tells the story of
how at age 10 lancelot along with
jericho went missing presumably due to
the involvement of the lady of the lake
lancelot returns six years later in the
four nights of the apocalypse but he
doesn't reveal his true identity until
chapter 47 when he finally assumes a
human form we learned that lancelot is
actually in the service of the king of
leonis who is of course meliodas
lancelot is a sort of secret agent of
meliodas who has been tasked with
locating the four nights of prophecy aka
the four knights of the apocalypse and
bringing them together in leonis this is
why lancelot took such an interest in
percival and why he brought him to
leonis to meet king meliodas despite
being an incredibly strong warrior most
people have never even heard of lancelot
that is because he doesn't allow his
opponents to survive for long enough to
spread rumors about him if anyone
challenges him to a battle it will be
the last thing that he or she will ever
do that is just so freaking badass and
ruthless and to be honest taking care of
loose ends in this way makes perfect
sense for a guy whose job is to
essentially be a secret agent from
chapter 346.5
we know that lancelot had exceptional
physical strength fast reflexes and
combat capabilities even as a 10 year
old and six years later all of these
abilities have increased exponentially
lancelot is a highly skilled archer and
he uses a bow and arrow with amazing
speed and accuracy as mentioned earlier
he possesses transformation magic and it
is this magic that allows him to turn
into a fox then of course when he turns
himself into a fox he becomes a much
smaller target for his opponents on top
of that he has incredible offensive
capabilities both with his arrows and
with his bare hands he was able to
instantly kill doranok one of the holy
knights of camelot with just a single
punch to the abdomen and if that wasn't
enough lancelot can read the minds of
his opponents an ability also known as
heart reading this is yet another useful
trait that he inherited from the fairy
clan finally he has a magical ability
called shining road which allows him to
fire a beam of light at an opponent this
beam of light will then chase after its
target and follow it like a heat-seeking
missile until it finds it and destroys
it next up let's talk about tristan the
16 year old son of meliotis and
elizabeth according to the prophecy
tristan is the knight of pestilence and
he is described as a boy who has both
holiness and evil in his eyes which is a
reference to the fact that he is the son
of a demon and a goddess like lancelot
we actually met tristan in the original
seven deadly sins manga he appears as a
10 year old kid in chapter 346
which serves as the concluding chapter
of the original manga series tristan
appears again six years later in chapter
54 of the sequel manga tristan is the
prince of leones and he has an entire
order of holy nights under his command a
group of knights known as the tristan
platoon prince tristan appears to be
cool-headed and benevolent and he is
well loved by his people and his
subordinates as the son of meliotis and
elizabeth he possessed above average
physical power and fighting capabilities
since he was still a child and he has
inherited the ability to use both
goddess and demon powers from his
parents he can even manifest these two
completely different types of powers at
the same time and he can use a wide
variety of goddess and demon abilities
including incredible healing powers his
techniques tend to have the word star in
the name such as twinkling star and
healing star he also has two swords that
he uses in battle one sword is black and
the other is white interestingly enough
in one of the question corners author
nakabasuzuki revealed that tristan's two
favorite swords are named miel and
esterosa
the fourth and final knight of the
apocalypse is gawain the only female
member of the group according to the
prophecy gawain is the knight of famine
and she is described as a person who
possesses gold colored magic this gold
colored magic is none other than
sunshine the divine grace that was
originally possessed by mael and later
inherited by escanor gawain somehow
inherited the power after the tragic
death of escondor and she openly calls
herself the master of the sun she also
uses a weapon called sacred sword rita
which is a direct reference to
eskanore's divine axe rita gawain is the
niece of king arthur pendragon who of
course has been portrayed as the main
villain of the four knights of the
apocalypse series at least for now just
like eschanor when we first meet him in
his daytime form gawain is extremely
egotistical and full of herself she
refuses to listen to orders from anyone
because she believes herself to be the
strongest and so she believes that she
herself should be giving out all the
orders she also refuses to consider
herself as being in the same league as
the other three nights of prophecy since
she sees herself as superior to all of
them thanks to the power of sunshine
gawain has unbelievable physical power
and she likes to dominate her enemies
using brute force
however her moves are very basic and
predictable which proves that despite
her awesome power she is still an
amateur when it comes to combat an
experienced holy knight with superior
fighting techniques can still defeat her
which is exactly what holy night of
camelot pellegard does needless to say
gawain is nowhere near the level that
eschanor was when we first met him
because there's just no way on earth
that daytime escana would have lost to a
single holy night in battle after she
loses to peligard gawain throws a
childish tantrum and she refuses to
accept the reality of the situation
tristan is able to calm her down by
showering her with a bunch of
compliments some of which were outright
lies so despite possessing sunshine
daytime gawain is still a cocky spoiled
brat with a lot of work to do before she
can match the kind of power that escanor
once wielded she's also nowhere near as
cool as eskanor was and her one-liners
can't even compare to the true master of
the sun on top of sunshine gawain also
has other overpowered magical abilities
she is able to use strong spells like
absolute cancel to cancel out a perfect
cube and she can also use advanced
teleportation magic to instantly
teleport from one spot to another this
suggests that gawain may have had some
contact with merlin in the past
especially since we know that she is
directly related to king arthur gawain
may have even trained under merlin at
some point although this is yet to be
confirmed despite her family connection
to king arthur and camelot gawain
doesn't appear to be loyal to camelot
and in fact tristan believes that she
will fight on the side of leonis against
the forces of king arthur and that is it
all four knights of the apocalypse and
their powers explained at least in terms
of everything that we know so far
the four nights of the apocalypse manga
is still relatively new but i'll be sure
to keep you guys informed about all the
important future updates as long as you
click subscribe and hit that
notification bell right now you can also
drop a like and comment to help this
video with that youtube algorithm feel
free to follow me on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar and definitely
let me know how you're enjoying the
manga so far i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the red-haired fox hinokami and
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
fallen chosen orihime wukong dante
tinnell and big buddhist finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor bonnie parks
fatboy games kaido might be a duck
alivania and anime s codem if you guys
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys